let me ask you this because there's  draco the ruler  and then you're draco and i talked to  him and he was  i don't think he was too fond that you  call yourself draco  but when you started calling yourself  draco did you know about draco the ruler  because draco's obviously what people  refer to as a gun  in general right so i feel like it was  more of a coincidence maybe you could  kind of you know  shed some light on that my name is  deandre cortez  everybody call me dre my middle name  cortez the second  first two letters of cortez the ceo is  draco  that's my name so that is why  that makes sense deandre cortez draco  that's my name like what the [ __ ]  yeah i think that that was just  something that this is like i'm glad you  explained that  yeah that's my name yeah because he's  doing his thing you're doing your thing  it's like  it's not you know they can both things  can be true